الى العراق الى العراق هناك اثار احد
المعلمين الجدل بعد تسريب مقطع له وهو
يهين طالبه اثناء درس في احد المعاهد
الخاصه المقطع تبين انه يعود مشاهدينا
لمعلم كيمياء شهير في بغداد يتابع مئات
الالاف عبر التواصل الاجتماعي ومنصاتها
ومعروف بسلاسه شرحه وعلاقه المقربه من
تلاميذه لكن المقطع المنتشر تسبب في غضب
كبير تجاه هذا المعلم وراى كثيرون ضروره
معاقبته وحتى وقفه عن التدريس وزاره
التربيه العراقيه اصدرت بيانا تقول فيه
انها شكلت لجنه عاجله للتحقيق حول مقطع
الفيديو هذا على العموم نتابع المزيد مع
زينب المشاط من العراق في هذا التقرير
وعن نقلها بين الاجيال بهدوء جدل يحدثه
معلم الكيمياء بعد تسريب مقطع فيديو له
وهو يهين طالباته في احد المعاهد الخاصه
التي يعمل بها في بغداد
محاضره اليوم
الذي عرف بين طلابه بادائه العلمي المتميز
يحال الى مجلس تحقيقي من قبل وزاره
التربيه العراقيه وبمهله ثمانيه واربعين
ساعه للكشف عن اسباب تصرفه المخالف تماما
لصفته المهنيه كتربوي اولا ومن ثم كمعلم
غسب منير
المتابعون ان الطالبات هن من اخرجنا
المعلمه عن شعوره بينما يجد اخرون ان هذا
السلوك هو السلوك المعتاد لهذا المعلم
ولاخرين غيره فمن امن العقاب اساء الادب
كما علق رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
الذين اتفقوا على ان المعاهد الخاصه باتت
بؤره خطره على طلاب والطالبات لما فيها من
مخالفات مسكوت عنها زينب المشاط صباح
العربيه بغداد
احنا مشاهدينا من العراق والاردن سالنا
الناس متى يصبح حزم المعلم على طلابه مؤذي
نفسيا خلينا نشوف سؤال
هو واجب المعلم بدوره انه يكون منصح
ما نتعرض لازم من خلاله لا العنف جسدي ولا
العنف معنوي اكو طرق هلا هوايه بموضوع
التدريس لازم تتبع هاي الطرق لما تتجاوز
مثلا يصير في اساءه لفظيه اساءه جسديه هنا
يعني يكون يتجاوز حده
يعني كنا نخاف على المعلم مالنا قاعد
بالقهوه احنا نتجنب الطريق الثاني حين
يقتل عن تاثير الكلمات التي يقولها نوعيه
الكلمات التي يقولها على النشئ الجديد او
الاطفال اللي او الاعمار المبكره يعني
انه مهمه الطالب المفروض المعلم انه ما
ينزل المستوى الطالب
مؤذي لما الحزم يبطل يصب في مصلحه الطالب
لما ياثر على نفسيه الطالب على ثقه الطالب
في نفسه على يعني كيف بعبر الطالب عن نفسه
بين زملائه في المدرسه
يعني لازم يكون نوعا ما بتعرف شو اللي هي
التوازن او اللي هو الوسطيه في التعامل مع
الامور لا يكون كثير شد على الطلاب ولا
يكون كثير مرخي مع الطلاب لازم يكون في
اولا في بين الاستاذ والطفل احترام متبادل
مبدئيا يعني احترام المتبادل عشان ما يكون
الحزم بزياده على الطالب يعني طول ما
الطفل ضمن الحدود طول ما الاستاذ الامور
بينهم بتكون طبيعيه لكن عندما يعني بيكون
الطفل نص نص طبعا بده يكون الاستاذ الحزم
عليه اكثر يعني بس طبعا ضمن الحدود بحزمه
المعلم على الطالب يعني بكون هو عباره عن
تنبيه بالكلام الشفوي
ويكون يعني الضرب طبعا مش مسموح يعني بكون
مؤذي للطفل نفسه خصوصا بالاعمار الصغيره
فبكون عباره عن تنبيه شفوي
مشاهدينا من بغداد الاستاذه شيماء الجنابي
التربويه في تربيه بغداد الكرخ الثانيه
اهلا فيكي استاذه شيماء معنا استاذه شيماء
اذا حكينا عن الفيديو نفسه هل هذا سلوك
تربوي صحيح استاذ يتكلم حتى وان لم يعني
لم يستعمل العنف الجسدي بالضرب او كذا
ولكن بالالفاظ هل هذا شيء مقبول تربويا
انه يحكي مع الطالبه بهذا الاسلوب طبعا
هذا
طبعا هذا السلوك غير مقبول اسلوب غير
تربوي لكن للاسف
العنف هو
ثقافه متجذره في المجتمع العراقي وفي
المجتمعات الابويه الذكوريه
الكثير يتغنى بهذا الاسلوب ويعتقد بان هذا
الاسلوب قد صنع نساء وصنع رجالا فربما
ينطلق البعض من هذا المفهوم للتعامل مع
طلابه استاذه شيماء يعني اليوم خليني انا
اخذ ايضا اقف على الاقل لا نستطيع ان نحكم
على مشهد هذا الفيديو لانه ما ندري الطالب
هي طالبه ماذا عملت وبالتالي ما الرساله
اذا كان معه حق من رساله الذي نوجهها
للطلاب
عمل الطالب مهما عمل الطالب لابد للمعلم
ان يكون محتوي
للطالب ان يكون هو مقوم لسلوك الطالب
لا يكون التعامل هو انسان وهو في طور
تكوين الشخصيه هو مراهق اليوم هو ينتقل من
مرحله الطفوله الى مرحله الشباب وليس
شيماء انا اتكلم عن المعلم كامله في
الحياه استاذه شيماء يعني احنا نقول قفل
المعلم وفيه التبجيله هل نريد اليوم من
المعلم ان يكون هو ممنون للطالب النجاه
يتعلم
كيف كيف نقف للمعلم وهو لا يحترم وهو لا
يعرف كيف ينتقي الفاظه بدقه اذا كان
الطالب غلطان يا استاذه شيماء
حتى لو كان الطالب مختصر حتى لو كان
الطالب مسيء هذا الاسلوب ليس صحيحا في
تقويم يعني استاذه انت ما تقولين ما
تقولين بانه يعني
حتى وان كان هناك سلوك غير سوي من قبل
الطلاب
الاستاذ يتحمل مسؤوليه اكبر لانه هو بالغ
عاقل وهو في موقع
يتحمل المسؤوليه الكبرى في تصحيح سلوك
الطالب الاستاذ هو صانع للانسان طيب وين
الحد الفاصل لانه مطلوب من الاستاذ انه
يكون حازم في بعض الاوقات مع الطلاب لازم
يكون في نوع من النظام وين الحد الفاصل
اللي بيقدر يمارس في هذا الحزم بدون ما
يتعدى
هنالك حكمه تقول احترم تحترم انا عندما
اقدم الاحترام لطلابي ساقابل بالاحترام
الحزم ممكن ان يكون
باستخدام الضوابط الضوابط المفروضه علينا
من قبل وزاره التعليم
طالب هل تعرفين شيئا لا نعرفه يعني هل هل
انت تعرفين كامل القصه اليوم اذا اذا كان
الطالب هو ربما تجرا على الاستاذ امام
الطلبه كيف ناخذ موقف
ضد الاستاذ ونعاقبه ما الرساله التي
نوجهلها للاجيال اخذوا راحتكم وعلى المدرس
ان يتحمل
عاد مع المدرسين
لا لا طبعا لا طبعا
صاحب
رساله كل مدرسه يوجد باحث اجتماعي يوجد
مرشد تربوي هذا دور المرشد التربوي دور
المرشد التربوي وكذلك دور الاهل عليهم
ابنائهم على وين دور الاهل في هذه في في
مشاكل من هذا النوع يعني زمان كانوا
الاهلي يشجعوا المعلم على تربيه الولد ولو
اضطر انه يضربه ويضربه ما في مشكله
ولكن الان النظره مختلفه الان انا مش راح
ارسل لا ارسل ابنائي للمدرسه حتى ينهانوا
نعم كانت في تلك الفتره هذه هي الثقافه
السائده الثقافه الذكوريه الابويه نحن
كلنا تعرضنا للتعنيف قد تكون قد نفعت هذه
في وقت من الاوقات لاننا لم نكن نعرف ما
هي حقوقنا لكن هذه الاجيال تعرف ما هي
حقوقها بحكم الانفتاح بحكم الاطلاع فهذا
الاسلوب لم يعد نافع في الوقت الحاضر ست
شيماء يعني مع كامل التقدير والاحترام
لوجهه نظرك لكن ايضا هذا الجيل ليس جيل
ملائكه البعض قد يخطئ والبعض ايضا قد يفقد
يفقد ما احنا كنا على عليه من تقديم كل
هذا التقدير والاحترام للمدرس واحنا
ممنونين لهم بالمحصله النهائيه ننهل من
علمهم
لكن اكيد في حدود يعني ما يتغول
طيب
طبعا
هم ليسوا ملائكه ولكن يبقى اسلوب العنف هو
اسلوب غير صحيح ممكن ان نستخدم اسلوب
الحوار اسلوب الحوار تستخدم كل دول العالم
المتقدم في تنشئه الاجيال شكرا جزيلا
الاستاذه شيماء الجنابي التربويه في تربيه
بغداد الكرخ الثاني شكرا جزيلا لك وان
اختلفت انا مع وجهه نظرك فاسمحي لي هذا
ربما انا اميل للمدرسين
المدرس لغه عربيه
فبالتالي تحياتنا لكل هؤلاء المدرسين
والتربويين بده توازن سهل
عندما يؤثر على معدله الدراسي او يعني
مثلا يؤذيه دراسيا ما الطفل ما يقدر مثلا
يتعلم يصير المدرسه عنده شيء مؤذي اذا كان
مودي للطالب يعني في طرق يعني توصل
المعلومه للطالب بدون ما تجرحه الحين
العلم الحمد لله تطور
وتكنولوجيا متقدمه تقدر توصل للطالب
المعلومه بيسر سهوله بدون حنا درست الدرسي
ومعلمين للاسف يعني
كلها لك صادق يعني للحين في معلمين يكرهم
الان اشوفهم عندنا بالديره والله اكرههم
طبعا اذا اذا حصلت الاذيه يعني
سواء الاذيه النفسيه او الاذيه
الجسديه اكيد سيكون الحزم هذا مؤذي
لما الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات